[Musique]
pendant des siècles nous avons envoyé
des messages dans l'univers en espérant
une réponse
en 2024 l'univers
réponds enfin
envoyer nous votre chef
[Musique]
c'est moi est-ce que tu m'entends chéri
je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime
c'est rigolo
[Musique]
veuillez m'indiquer votre monde
d'origine la terre bienvenue chef de e
la terre
nous sommes l'Union des aliens
supérieurs de l'univers il doit y avoir
une petite erreur vous n'êtes pas le
chef de e la terre désolé pour la
confession effacement de mémoire
attendez
oui je suis bien le chef de la terre
pourquoi votre voix change-t-elle j'ai
toujours parlé comme ça depuis que je
suis enfant même si je suis grand
aujourd'hui évidemment alors oui je
dirige la planète le procès de e la
terre peut avoir lieu
en attendant comme on dit sur eux la
terre ok à plus tard je t'aime à plus
tard je t'aime je t'aime
[Musique]
univers partent de toi j'aimerais
tellement puisse me voir ouais je te
comprends à ma naissance j'ai mangé ma
mère et chaque fois que je connais la
gloire je le regrette c'est quelque
chose que vous faites souvent ici non il
y a que moi qui l'ai fait ça fait tout
un scandale
[Musique]